[Music]
your father died protecting this city he
taught you to follow your conscience in
an often cruel world
what happened worst day of 18 years how
many cops
hey why were they here they responded to
a robbery
automatic weapons to shooters they have
training Oh what were you when your
father's captain King I asked for you
for a reason I will find out we just
kick him either one you got to move fast
cosmatos plates are stolen we will catch
these guys in the next three or four
hours they vanished
are you gonna do this close the eyelet
got 21 bridges in and out of Manhattan
shut him down
Three Rivers closed four tunnels block
oh stop every train and loop the subways
then we flood the island now that is
nice sense the bid was for 30 keys we
walked into 300
they'll have to open Manhattan by
morning eight dead policeman is one
thing but the stock market there's in
billions of dollars is quite another
this whole thing is filthy you know I
mean you've got to be the move to be
hundred kilos of cocaine what's going on
here I just need the truth that's all I
told me you were feeling the guy who
kills cop killers
sees his dad and every couple dies
your culture is one
[Music]
we know they're not gonna escape defy
this can only come tonight who speaks
first second I will find out why denied
happy
to try to represent
[Music]